bonjour bonjour et bienvenue en 2019
j'espère que vous avez fait bon voyage
pour venir ici
moi quand j'avais quand j'avais 18 ans
j'ai rencontré un homme qui lui avait
fait un voyage incroyable il avait fait
france un aller-retour en stop pour 75
dollars c'est pas mal hein et puis vous
savez c'est dur personne quand il vous
raconte ses histoires vous avez
l'impression que c'est vous qui avez la
casquette lé sac à dos qui attendait
comme ça à côté de l'autoroute
alors moi quand lui me racontait ses
histoires je me suis dit ben la voilà
pourquoi quand je cherche c'est ça que
je veux faire de ma vie moi aussi tu
vois je veux partir découvrir le monde
alors bon vous imaginez que la première
fois que j'en ai parlé à ma mère c'est
pas super bien passé 1 la pause les prix
au petit déj elle était en train de
manger son humour tranquillement puis sa
réaction et c'était un petit peu genre
pour un tour du monde mais tu t'es fait
larguer tu sais pas va déjà faire un
tour d'immeuble c'est pas mal hein va
acheter du pain revient à midi puis on
en rediscute un thé en écrasant son
humour comme ça à la télé je le voyais
en train de faire compressé alors bon je
suis allé lui acheter sa baguette
et puis quatre ans plus tard je suis
parti et j'ai vendu le plus possible des
affaires du peu d'affaires que j'avais
finalement plus le rêve j'ai mis dans un
sac à dos et puis j'ai pris la route
j'avais pas vraiment de date de retour
prévue à la base j'ai littéralement
quitter la france finalement ça a duré
14 mois
quatorze mois pendant lesquels j'ai
traversé une vingtaine de pays
j'ai essayé de le faire le plus possible
en stop ça s'est étalée sur cinq
continents j'ai compté ça il ya deux
semaines pour pour la conférence mais au
sol j'ai parcouru plus de 40000 km et
puis 40 milles c'est aussi la
circonférence de la planète terre vous
savez des fois on entend le monde est
petit non non non du tout j'ai passé des
heures et des heures à l'arrière de
voiture comme celle là où au bout de mon
doigt le chauffeur essaye de l'arrêt
avec des cailloux ça n'a pas marché à
l'arrière des camions aussi les camions
c'est un peu moins confortable mais toit
ouvrant donc c'est pas mal sauf quand il
pleut après cette photo on a pris trois
heures de pluie donc ça c'était un peu
moins fun et à l'arrière de pick up
alors les pick-ups c'est pas souvent
mais jackpot atteint pouvez communiquer
avec le chauffeur panorama la vitesse
non applicable c'est jackpot
la raison pour laquelle pour laquelle
j'ai pris la route c'est parce que je
voulais découvrir de nouvelles cultures
je voulais voir de rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes
je voulais vivre des expériences
intenses mais surtout surtout ce que je
voulais c'était de la galère je veux de
la difficulté je voulais tenir face à
des défis au quotidien tu vois puis s'il
ya quelque chose dont je me suis rendu
compte assez rapidement
c'est que voyager de nos jours c'est
devenu très facile en tout cas beaucoup
plus facile qu'il ya quelques années et
ce grâce à plein de facteurs l'anglais
pratiqué presque partout les vols low
cost la connexion internet aussi les
blogs
enfin il y en a plein et puis ça pousse
de plus en plus de monde à voyager
tant mieux c'est j'encourage tout le
monde ici à le faire je veux dire il ya
encore quelques années quand tu disais
un proche que tu partais en back pack
design mais ça va pas là qu'est ce que
tu vas coupe était carte d'identité
comme le mec dans le film tu es alors
qu'aujourd'hui vous dites que vous
partez de moins assidus en asie du sud
est
on m'a offert à hu jia trop conne moi
j'ai un ami en ce moment il y au chili
fait comme toi non je vais au cambodge
malheureusement cette démocratisation du
bac packing elle a aussi des effets
pervers
la première c'est que l'effet de masse
créer un effet de communautés et les
backpacker à l'international se
retrouvent et restent entre eux et de
fait se distancie des locaux les locaux
eux identifient très bien les
backpackers maintenant et savent très
bien ce qu'il vient de faire ici les
relations deviennent purement
commerciale on n'est plus dans un
échange de culture on est dans un
échange de services je dire c'est un
frein à la compréhension une culture
locale
aujourd'hui plein de gens partent pour
être face à de nouvelles croyances et de
nouvelles habitudes de vie mais c'est
très facile de passer toutes tes
journées avec des gens qui ont une
culture extrêmement similaire à la
tienne et ce même à l'autre bout du
monde
de plus en plus de gens sur la route
c'est aussi de plus en plus de blogs et
de notes absurde sur cinq des lieux
touristiques desquels on s'inspire avant
de se déplacer mais ça nous pousse à
aller au même endroit parce que de base
à chacun son voyage à chacun sa durée
son budget son trajet mais plus le temps
passe au plus on commence à faire les
mêmes parcours on va réaliser les mêmes
activités affaires qui se font
d'ailleurs soit dit en passant bien
souvent au détriment des considérations
environnementales ou de la bientraitance
des animaux on s'entend mais donc les
voyages se standardise et sont de moins
en moins propre à chacun ce qui peut
être très confortable je le comprends
parce que oui tu peux monter dans
n'importe quel but 'suite à un sentiment
de liberté mais beaucoup partent pour
casser la routine pour vivre quelque
chose de différent des autres et avec
cette uniformisation des parcours en
back pack on retrouve la linéarité et la
zone de confort conflit à la base cette
zone de confort dans laquelle on laisse
peu de place à l'imprévu finalement je
veux dire si tu veux sauter à pieds
joints dans l'inconnu pourquoi tu
regardes avant sur internet de quoi ça a
l'air les pays deviennent des choses à
faire des choses à rayer de la liste
savez des fois on entend une fois plus
que deux mois pour faire le pérou 2 mois
1 et on on peut faire des spaghettis oui
là je t'en fais si tu as faim ont fait
l'amour mais depuis quand on fait un
pays dire c'est ça me paraît super
prétentieux par rapport à tout ce qui
peut nous offrir non imaginez on prend
un exemple ici au québec deux étrangers
un point
un français en france à une française il
a plein ça pullule en ce moment ils
viennent ici en vacances au québec
ils vont faire une randonnée en gaspésie
et vont monter le mont royal ils vont
manger une poutine et puis on dira ce
bon on a fait le québec l'été dernier
non non non pas du tout pas du tout un
pays c'est un endroit dans lequel tu vas
et où tu vis des choses avant d'en
sortir c'est pas quelque chose que tu
peux compléter comme un jeu vidéo
aujourd'hui je vais je vais vous parler
d'un auteur certains connaissent
peut-être
il s'appelle ivan illitch ivan illitch
sa pensée c'est que un moyen une
technique à partir du moment où elle est
institutionnalisée c'est à dire où elle
est utilisée par tous ou presque
elle passe un seuil à partir duquel elle
nui au but qu'elle est censée servir à
la base donc je vous donnais des
exemples un peu plus concret une voiture
cet objet est incroyable à qui est censé
propulser un humain à à plus de 100 km
qui peut nous faire aller beaucoup plus
vite de partout alors aujourd'hui on
n'en possèdent tous une et regarder ce
qui se passe tous les matins on est
bloqué dans les embouteillages la
voiture en vient à nous faire perdre du
temps les communications
on cherche à multiplier les canaux à
augmenter leur efficience maximiser
leurs portes et tout ça mais aujourd'hui
on est tellement bombardés
d'informations qu'on n'est plus capable
de les retenir et on n'est plus capable
de distinguer le vrai du faux
donc vous commencez à saisir ce que veut
dire
ivan illitch mon plan aujourd'hui c'est
que le bac packing notre moyen en
l'occurrence il faut qu'on soit tous
vigilants parce que il ne passe pas ce
seuil à partir duquel il pourra plus
nous apporter ce qu'on va chercher dans
voyage et ce peu importe la raison pour
laquelle vous allez voyager sortir de
votre zone de confort rencontrer de
nouvelles cultures brûlées peu importe
parce que je suis là je suis pas là pour
vous dire ne pas voyager aujourd'hui et
bien au contraire
parce que premièrement je n'aurai aucune
légitimité à le faire on s'entend puis
deuxièmement certes ya des petits côtés
négatifs dans voyage
un exemple j'ai développé une calvitie
précoce à 24 ans parce que j'ai mal mené
mes cheveux pendant 14 mois bon ça fait
partie du jeu 1
ouais et alors c'est vrai avec ma coupe
j'ai essayé ça marche pas on le voit le
trou qui mange mon crâne comme ça
j'aurais bien face à vous aujourd'hui
non non à part ça le voyage c'est
surtout une opportunité incroyable de
découvrir et d'accepter l'autre et soi
même de réaliser qu'il ya pas de vérité
il ya que des choses auxquelles on croit
à une échelle plus collective cette
démocratisation du bac packing c'est
finalement un levier extraordinaire pour
la cohésion sociale ici pour la simple
et bonne raison que si de plus en plus
de gens par ce voyage est de plus en
plus de gens vont revenir encore plus
ouvert d'esprit prêt à construire une
société plus juste
bon une fois qu'ils ont pris une douche
où il fut d'accord ouais c'est lorsqu'on
a un cliché parfois jetés en caroline du
nord
après cinq jours jeux randonnées
sentiment là bien lourd ce qui est passé
comme ça là et qu'il arrivait devant moi
m'a fait non aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que j'ai une dette envers
l'humanité
avec tous ces gens qui m'ont accueilli
partout qui m'ont fait découvrir leur
culture alors que personne les avait
accueillis nulle part puis j'ai une
autre dette aussi et ça il faut en
parler mais j'ai une dette envers la
planète
bah oui c'est c'est un désastre
écologique que j'ai perpétré puisse à se
propre à mon cas mais aillent tous les
transports que j'ai pris j'ai explosé
mon empreinte carbone je me suis endetté
sur plusieurs années parce que parce que
ça on oublie souvent de mentionner quand
on pense au voyage
on pense que c'est juste du fun c'est un
truc cool avant que je parte j'entendais
des fois des jambes dures heures vas-y
avant d'avoir des responsabilités
profite un peu comme c'était juste une
pause dans ma vie que j'allais revenir
et que j'allais être la même mais
attends attends bien regarde regarde
tu vois tu crois que tu es du fun ça non
non pas du tout 1
j'ai cru que j'allais esprit que
j'allais rester dix ans dans ce désert
la rue jetté punis non un voyage
ça te transforme parce que c'est le
terrain propice pour une introspection
et pourquoi un voyage nous transforme
il faut laisser nous transformer et ça
et ça selon moi ça passe par
l'expérience qui sert de habituel de 100
% mais surtout elle doit être personnel
parce que oui tu peux aller prendre les
mêmes photos que tu as vu sur les
réseaux sociaux les retoucher et puis
les mettre sur instagram à ton tour ça c
est possible mais jamais tu rencontreras
les mêmes personnes jamais tu vivras la
même chose si c'est ça me paraît fou que
contredit ce train soit plus facile de
faire rêver les autres que te fait rêver
soi même donc quand j'ai réalisé ça
quand j'ai réalisé que je vivais pas mon
voyage comme je l'avais imaginé parce
que oui oui j'ai parcouru des dizaines
de milliers de kilomètres en stop
oui je me suis lancé dans des histoires
bizarres elle a été de baisser dès que
j'ai pu oui j'ai cru que j'allais y
passer trois quatre fois en finale
j'avais une carte bancaire avec de
l'argent dessus j'avais jeu
ressortissant d'un pays où il ya des
ambassades de partout dans le monde au
cas où il m'arrive quelque chose
j'avais un téléphone je veux dire c'est
un vrai aventurier
c'est pas vrai donc quand j'ai réalisé
cela j'ai réagi et aujourd'hui je vais
je vais terminer ma conférence comme
j'ai terminé mon voyage sur mon
téléphone
pas tant pour ses calvitie ça aurait un
peu pauvre non j'ai parcouru les
derniers milliers de kilomètres qui me
restait avant d'arriver en europe dont
de douchanbé la capitale du tadjikistan
jusqu'à moscou
sans ça puis à la place j'avais ça je
sais pas si vous vous rappelez ce que
c'est moi j'avais complètement oublié et
en fait c'est un s'est incarnée et on
peut on peut écrire des choses alors on
peut pas régler luminosité et contraste
mais peut-être des choses à faire mais
en attendant on peut écrire et ça reste
alors c'est sûr que au début tout
devient plus compliqué oui j'ai dû
écrire les devises du crime un
calendrier pour compter les jours j'ai
dû acheter une montre pas ce que j'avais
pu leur j'ai acheté une carte à puce gps
j'ai acheté une boussole ça c'est parce
que ça fait style est d'avoir une
boussole c'est mais met donc tout est
plus compliqué mais très rapidement j'ai
aussi réalisé que tout est plus
authentique tout est plus intense chacun
des moments de mes journées est
redevenue une expérience et un
apprentissage
c'est tout ce qu'il y avait autour de
relever la tête tout ce qu'il y avait
autour de moi ça revenez des outils
qu'ils pouvaient m'aider dans mon voyage
des panneaux jusqu'aux personnes tout
même le trajet aller d'un point a à un
point b
parce que ça c'est l'essence du voyage
même ça c'est devenu tu es une
expérience tu es un peu tu attend que ça
passe comme ça là quand tu as un
téléphone du feeling
non même ça sans téléphone ça redevient
une expérience j'ai retrouvé mon sens de
l'orientation
je savais même pas que j'avais perdu et
non ça ça vraiment complètement changé
mon voyage j'ai déconnecté
mais je me suis complètement reconnecter
avec ce que je voulais et finalement
voilà je sais que cette conférence tout
ce que vous allez retenir c'est que la
planète terre fait quarante mille
kilomètres de circonférence avec la
capitale du tadjikistan c'est douchanbé
mais s'il vous plaît la prochaine fois
vous partez faire un voyage ne fait pas
un beau voyage
c'est assez facile
les agences de voyages vous en vendre
plein en plus de ça au canada on peut
faire ça dans son canapé légalement
depuis octobre dernier mais non là la
prochaine fois ne fait pas un beau
voyage n'ont fait un fait un vrai voyage
fait votre voyage merci
[Applaudissements]